the clock is Charming in the background
we live right good evening
everybody Welcome to the cabinet meeting
for
November um fire alarm procedures if the
fire alarm is activated loate the
offices V the stairs please do not use
the lifts assemble in hly square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it's deemed safe to return
to the chamber please switch off or turn
to silent your mobile phones and do not
make or receive calls while the meetings
in progress this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be available on the
internet does anyone intend to film the
meeting the following members have asked
to speak under Council procedure 20.1
item six counselor Davis item 10
counselor bayford item 11 councelor
Garner and item 12 councelor Pew any
other members wish to speak under 20.1
councelor scobby uh agenda item six
please
chair
uhuh Council Austin agenda items six and
eight please chair and apologies from
Council garana who can't be here after
all sorry okay six and eight you don't
wish to speak on his behalf on the on
the broads st's neighborhood plan review
thank you
do right members we're all here so there
can't be any apologies thank you uh does
anyone have any deck cations of interest
in the items of business on the agenda
this
evening no thank you uh item three to
approve the summary and recommendations
decisions of the cabinet meeting held on
the 19th of October propose we take the
minutes as R do I have a second I
councilor Yates thank you and we move on
to the first substantive item which is
item four the budget monitoring report
number two 2023 24 councilor y thank you
leader I present the second budget
monitoring report to cabinet for its
consideration and approval the key
financial me messages are that our
general fund net revenue spending is
forecast to be approximately 1.2 million
over budget which is L largely due to an
anticipated overspend on temporary
accommodation for homelessness and a
shortfall against some of our income
streams um just want to mention that
overspend is not at all unusual at this
time of year um and this does not raise
any serious concerns about the council's
finances as a whole um furthermore key
financial messages are that all budgets
will continue to be regularly monitored
to ensure the council's expenditure
remains wherever possible within the
agreed budget in our housing revenue
account I'm pleased to report that we
are forecasting a 1.4 million pound
Surplus against the budget which is
mainly due to better Returns on our H
investment balances and reduced debt
charges section 6.5 and 6.6 of the
report also set out some recommended
changes to our Capital program including
increasing the budget for disabled
adaptations in our res homes following
the receipt of additional external
funding I move the
recommendations thank you counc
second councelor
Whitehead members any comments on the
budget
report very unusual not to have any 20.1
speakers on a on a budget
report okay members is that is the
recommendations agreed agreed agreed
thank
you moving on to item five the midyear
review 2023 24 treasury management and
annual investment strategy Council Yates
thank you leader following on from the
review of our budget position this
report gives a mid-year update on how
we've managed our cash balances
Investments and borrowings over the same
period the regulatory environment places
responsibility on members for the review
and scrutiny of Treasury management
policy and activities this report is
important in that respect as it provides
details of the 2324 midyear position for
treasury activities the key items to
consider are the we have maintained our
internal borrowing strategy where we are
using our own cash Holdings to finance
our Capital spending plans rather than
taking on external borrowing for
instance our need to borrow to finance
our capital expenditure is estimated to
be 78.3 million at 31st of March 2024
however our actual gross debt at 30th
September 2023 was 19.7 Million despite
utilizing a proportion of our cash
balances for our capital expenditure
needs at 30th September 2023 the
council's invest investment balance was
still high 55.4 million there are two
changes to our treasury manage
management strategy that are recommended
for cabinets approval which is set out
at section three of the report it is
proposed that both our operational
boundary and our authorized limit for
borrowing be increased by 20 million to
reflect the increase in the 2023 to 24 h
capital program for the acquisition and
development of new affordable housing
units I move the
recommendations thank you councel yikes
there a second
councelor
Duckworth members any
comments no is that agreed agreed thank
you move on to item six the external
Auditor's annual audit report on value
for money councilor
Yates thank you leader each year the
council's external auditor is required
to report its audit findings from its
audit of the accounts to the governance
and audit committee which Gran thoron
will present at the committee meeting on
the 29th of November however this this
year due to the fact that this report
covers three years rather than one it is
also being brought to the contention of
cabinet for noting the report on value
for money covers the three years from
2021 from sorry from
2020 I'll rephrase uh the report on the
value for money covers three years 2020
to 21 21 to 22 and 22 to 23 it therefore
covers a period in the council's history
of significant upheaval and revisions to
its senior leadership and governance
Arrangements
it would be fair to say the the report
concludes that the first two of these
three years were a period in which the
necessary steps were being taken to
identify and address the problems the
last of those years 22 to 23 is a period
in which significant progress has been
made to resolve the problems and I'm
glad to report in relation to um uh the
working groups which are mentioned in
1.16 of the report um that significant
progress is being
made um on a property working group a
governance working group uh and a
project management working
group um the details of uh uh progress
and the process that has and is being
made to set out in the report um I
therefore I ask cabinet to consider and
note the auditor's annual report and to
comment on and endorse the management
action the next steps are for this
report to pass to the GNA committee for
further consideration where a
representative from Grant Thornton will
attend the committee meeting and present
the key findings I move the
recommendations thank you councelor
Yates a second councelor Alban and
speaking under 20.1 councelor
Davis thank you chair um good evening
members the uh the issue that I'd like
to not particularly raised but I think
we need to keep in the in the Forefront
of our uh observation and I and I
welcome a lot of the the the positive
news here and thank God we finally move
forward in 3 years of waiting uh I must
confess to be one of those that objected
to the item in the accounts that I'm
about to refer to and guess what it's
births four and five page 13 in the
auditor's report still outstanding work
going on but I would like to bring to
cabinet's attention a couple of points
um in that uh there are various
references to overpayments being made
and a need for audit on those uh and
compensation required if necessary um
the the whole contract situation
needs to be reviewed I believe um and in
the in the grant thornson report it does
state that um uh there's a need for an
immediate action on this um given the
amount of projects that are ongoing and
uh uh for instance the leveling up
projects which obviously there's quite a
lot of shift on and so on and a lot of
difficulty delivering could I have
cabinet or or certainly portfolio
holders confirmation that these
recommendations will be implemented
monitored and and and monitored
ongoing uh on an immediate basis because
we have no time to wait for this and as
the as the the auditor's report clearly
says if we carry on as we are we're
going to keep making the same mistakes
thank
you councelor y do you want to respond
to that yeah sure um
so just I want Focus just on the project
management side um it has been
identified within the auditor's report
about project management being an issue
um that is one of the working groups
that has now been set up within the
council um and these are led by the
senior directors in the council in order
to address some of the issues uh raised
um in these audit
reports um a bit of context I think is
needed on the leveling up um and Town
deal monies is that this was an
extremely rapid um announcement for the
council to react to so I don't think
it's too surprising that local councils
need to um react very quickly and I
think we're doing exactly what's
required by setting up this project uh
project management working group um but
I'm happy to feedback to officers uh
Chris bondal if he can um step in and
comment on a few of those points as well
thanks yeah thank thank you uh counselor
um a couple of points there that you've
raised in relation to that
recommendation um taking them turn the
project management item as uh councelor
Yates has referred to in this
introduction we are making progress we
setting up a number of those working
groups some of them have already met and
we're establishing the the terms of
reference for those groups to address
the recommendations that have been made
here also in the work of the internal
Auditors and also previous reports by
the external Auditors as well and the
independent monitoring officer all
that's been woven together to make sure
we are addressing those concerns that
have been raised around um project
management and our overall approach to
governance to make sure that's as tight
as it needs to be in terms of the the
issues relating to the contract
management that's right so it was an
area that was um identified as uh a
whistleblowing concern it was raised to
our internal audit team that was um
further investigated by management where
we identified that there had been um
overpayments in relation to a particular
service uh uh that was out to contract
we've been able to recover that money we
took the appropriate action to report
that um through our regular um fraud
reporting channels um it's also worth
noting the service area in relation to
um uh plan maintenance um where this uh
overpayment was identified was subject
to followup as part of the uh standard
internal audit process and the overall
opinion provided that service had
increased from limited to reasonable oh
no sorry no Assurance to reasonable
insurance which is quite a rapid
increase and a a markable turnaround to
show actually our controls are robust in
that area that said note the concerns
around um uh whether there could be and
there hasn't been identified but the
aits have put on record concerns that
there could be a wider uh incidence of
overcharging and we will look to
investigate that and make sure that our
controls are as tight as they need to be
but at this stage we haven't undertaken
that work because it's um it's a risk
that's being identified by the internal
Auditors that we are uh still currently
investigating thank you Chris that's uh
extremely encouraging if I can say so
because obviously there are still a lot
of ongoing concerns perhaps we could
have a conversation about one or two
items that members of the public have
identified or or stakeholders um but now
isn't obviously L the time but thank you
and thank you uh Rob very encouraging
thank you thank you councelor Davis
councelor
scobby thank you chair um I wanted to
speak about um issues related to
internal audit that have been raised by
the external auditor um I'm grateful to
council Yates for um come along to GNA
meetings I think that's been really
beneficial for members to know that
cabinet members there and listening to
concerns and also to you leader for
ensuring that this matter is discussed
at cabinet um it's a new governance and
AUD committee and we're still getting to
grips with some of the challenges and
one of the things that has uh come up
consistently in the last two agendas and
meetings before that is that we have had
um consistently low or no Assurance
given to some service areas coming out
from internal audit which is obviously a
concern and more recently that's covered
some really meaty areas like health and
safety and equalities now the
committee's had assurance that these
areas are being looked at and some of
the management controls are good uh but
one of the things I would like to
understand is how we're going to tackle
some of those challenges um I would also
be interested in whether we might need
to adjust the audit plan for the next 18
months because if we are seeing that
there's consistently service areas
coming in with limited or no Assurance
um from the ones that are being done it
may suggest that there are other areas
that do not have potentially the correct
management controls in place or
following the right process um audits a
lagging indicator and I will say that
the most recent trunch which is going to
the committee in about a week's time is
much more positive I think there was
only one area that had a partial
limitation around section 106 um but the
committee will look at that um so my I
would quite like at that meeting to give
reassurance to members that cabinet are
moving on this um and then there was
just one other small issue which is um
there's a recommendation that internal
audit themselves should be audited who's
auditing the Auditors um so it would be
good good to get some thoughts on
whether that might be able to be
achieved in 2024 or not because again I
think that would give particularly after
the rocky road of the last few years
some assurance that govern governance is
going back on track thank you
chair um thank you councelor scobby and
and I'm sure if um if the chief exec was
able to be here this evening he would um
offer you some some words of comfort in
terms of um his focus on dealing with
some of these outstanding issues but uh
uh councelor yakes you want to come in y
and thanks for the questions councelor
scobby um so I'll just return to what I
mentioned briefly in the intro which is
following on from this audit separate
working groups are coming up um Clause
1.16 report mentions these different
working groups one of these is the
governance working group so the terms of
reference of that working group has been
sent around the officers their first
meeting will be in the coming uh in the
coming weeks um and that will be
addressing some of the points raised at
the GNA meeting at I know from person
personal experience of being on GNA that
uh you can get a situation where it
could be like thanet Lotto for example
got low Assurance a few years ago and I
totally understand the position that GNA
is on which is how can we as as you as a
committee get assurance that these items
are being closed off and not just
turning up to next meeting where there's
new audit um findings um so we are
taking that on board and that will I
believe be discussed within um that
governance working group and it's
something that I'm taking on board with
the officers um for future uh reports um
onto health and safety as you brought
that up I just want to highlight that
following um the low Assurance um on
health and safety this has been brought
up in an internal meeting within cabinet
and c and Senior officers um and we will
be getting um a further follow-up uh
report in February on that um I don't
know what the next steps will be from
that but it'd be something that we'd be
Keen to um uh to provide feedback on to
be transparent um
following the next I believe in February
is actually the deadline for us to
feedback to the audit so um once that
feedback is provided I'm sure that's
something we can provide to counselors
to show uh progress on um who audits the
Auditors um it's a good question uh I'll
uh refer to uh our section 151 if that's
okay on that question thanks thank you
counselor
um I've got to be careful the Cho that
my choice of words the response on this
one um first and foremost I think it's
really important to stress how highly I
regard the work of East Kent audit
partnership um and actually if you look
through the substance if you look at the
substance of some of the themes that
have picked out in this report Grant
Thornton have actually been very um
favorable in terms of the view they've
given of the work of internal audits so
I think it's a bit harsh the
recommendation they've made is a bit
overly critical that they're saying to
ensure the internal audit are meeting
the right standards um there are you can
get an external body to come in and
review whether your independent audit in
internal audit function is doing as it
should do I don't have any concerns that
it isn't but I can understand why
members may wish to receive um that
level Assurance I think it would be more
of a concern if you were receiving a lot
of reports from internal audit with
saying there's nothing to see here
everything is substantial and reasonable
Assurance but you actually had concerns
about the way the service is being run
that for me would say you need to get
somethingone to look and look at the
work they're doing and assess the
quality the fact that you're getting
very Frank and um straightforward advice
from the internal audit service to me
suggest that there's not really a
problem here that would be uncovered as
part of an uh independent review but
nonetheless it's something that I I've
got no quarms or concerns about us
undertaking thank you Mr Mand uh counc
Austin thank you chair um I just wanted
to comment uh on the the report as a
whole that most particularly about the
governance which is an area that I've
personally been very involved in and
that we have as a green group and we
know the huge amount of work that's gone
on here and we're immensely grateful for
it and we do think there have been very
considerable
improvements
um however we are well aware that it's
still a work in progress and um speaking
as a member of the scrutiny committee
I'm delighted that this Administration
has committed itself to a level of
transparency that I haven't been
familiar with before uh in terms of
bringing everything to
scrutiny however there are still areas
particularly around project management
which concern us and where we've been
asking the chair has been asking for
reporting and that for one reason or
another has not happened on a regular
basis to scrutiny in the way that we had
hoped and um that's a concern that
there's been push back that that we
haven't been able to have some of the
reporting that we we had hoped for um
simple project management reporting red
Amber green type reporting not something
that should require a lot of extra work
from officers but areas that we were we
have been concerned about and I'm quite
happy to follow that up with a with an
email of that's that's helpful but I
know that the chair of scrutiny I think
has already raised that um the other
thing that surprises me about this
report not being familiar with these
types of reports is the covering report
is actually quite positive and
encouraging and when you deal with the
detail of the internal audit report
there's a lot of very positive things in
it and yet the executive summary is ah
you know that it looks really negative
it looks that we're like we're actually
getting worse or at least we were
getting worse at the point at which that
the the uh the papers were available uh
for the internal Auditors and I'm just
interested in Council yates's comments
on that and what he thinks the picture
will look like on the executive summary
uh in uh for the for the next for the uh
current year thank
you yeah it is necessarily a very
backward looking document of course and
uh I I I actually found it really useful
um as an overview of what of what G on
over over a period of time um counc
Yates yep and thank you counc a for your
questions um so project management
concerns as highlighted already we do
have the project management uh working
group which has already been set up had
their first meeting um I can I can
highlight that a new officer to support
with a project management framework is
due to start imminently um to support
officers um and as reiterating what I
said previous VI ly um I think the
leveling up town deal monies coming to
this Council without I think it's fair
to say without a large amount of forward
notice um does require us to kind of
catch up on some of these things
um so and as part of that uh this
council's signed up to the Pathfinder
project which means that we no longer
have all these separate boards meeting
uh and taking up a lot of a lot of time
and bureaucracy that we've streamlined
that process so that we can um uh reduce
the level of bureaucracy and get these
projects moving um I I agree with you
about the rag reporting and that's
something that um we uh would like to
see as well um so this that's just a bit
of a highlight a bit of a response on
the project
management um we are we are heading in
the right direction um on the executive
summary what predict ition what I hope
to see um well it's it's for the
internal Auditors to give their um uh
give their review and I don't really
want to um estimate what they will be
saying but I think given the incredible
amount of work given by this uh Colin
Carmichael our chief exec and the senior
officers um into taking this issue very
very seriously the working groups as
have mentioned being set up um I believe
that in a year's time we'll be looking
at much more positive report
thank you thank
you um thank you councelor Yates and I'm
sure counc atin you'll you'll let us
have an email in specific terms about
what you're talking about scrutiny
obviously it's a bit difficult for
cabinet um to comment on what can and
can't go to scrutiny because scrutiny
isn't accountable to Cabinet um but uh
I'm sure that there are some specific
challenges that you'll highlight and
we'll be able to get the officers to
respond to you on
that uh members anything further to add
to this item
okay um it's been moved and seconded um
is that agreed members agre thank you um
councilor Yates your your show goes on
with the ndr discretionary relief policy
thank you leader uh I present in this
report revised business rates
discretionary relief policy and
decision-making process for approval
local businesses are currently able to
apply for discretionary relief to
alleviate the burden of business rates
in certain circumstances The Proposal in
this report is to streamline and
amalgamate these existing policies in
this area and create two volumes for the
overall discretionary relief policy
volume one will be contained the
containing the discretionary release
that local authorities are effectively
obliged to award to businesses and
volume two covering what can be
considered uh true discretionary relief
uh this policy will make the overall
policy uh position much clearer more
transparent for applicants and easier to
update when the government either
removes a relief or announces a new
relief scheme I move the the
recommendations thank you council is
there a
second councilor K members do you wish
to discuss the discretionary rate relief
policy apparently not
okay is that agree
B thank
you okay uh extension to the alcohol
public space protection order item eight
and it's Council
K thank you
leader this report recommends a 9-month
extension to the public spaces
protection order or pspo which regulates
alcohol consumption in our district the
pspo has been in place since 2017 and
was renewed in
2020 it was introduced to tackle
antisocial behavior and public disorder
related to alcohol consumption in public
places and was requested by Kent Police
this includes Street drinking public
intoxication and disturbances caused by
alcohol related activities the pspo has
been successful in reducing these issues
and improving the safety and well-being
of the community since the covid-19
pandemic lockdowns there has been an
increase in the number of people
gathering in public places this has led
to more incidents of antisocial behavior
and public disorder related to alcohol
consumption over the last 3 years since
January 20 23 the police have issued 23
fixed penalty notices under the alcohol
pspo the pspo also allows alcohol to be
confiscated and disposed of without the
need for a fixed penalty notice to be
issued education and communication are
also key to reducing such instances and
their recurrence the recommended
short-term extension of 9 months to this
pspo will synchronize the expiry of the
order with that of the existing
antisocial Behavior p PSO it is likely
that a new combined antisocial behavior
and alcohol pspo will be drafted and
applied for prior to 31st of July
2024 during this time officers in the
community safety team will continue to
monitor the effectiveness of the order
and assess the potential for any
necessary adjustments to ensure it
remains an effective tool in regulating
alcohol consumption in public places the
team will also continue to work closely
with the police and other partners to
ensure consistent enforcement of the
order the council is committed to
creating a safer and healthier Community
for all our residents and visitors
extending the pspo will support this
goal and combat the antisocial behavior
and public disorder in our public spaces
for the benefit of all I moved the
recommendations thank you councelor K we
have secondar councelor Alvin and
speaking under 20.1 councelor
Austin thank you leader um I thoroughly
support this uh and I think it has had a
beneficial effect but certainly in
Ramsgate Town Center as officers and uh
members involved there no we have still
quite a serious problem with Street
drinkers uh many of those people are
known to the police and to our offices
and we don't we don't seem to be seeing
any pro ress in the support that those
people are getting and I know we we
asked um uh Miss Taylor a lot of
questions about this scrutiny and we've
had various discussions um out of
committees as well and we know that uh
the police are mostly trying to work on
a basis of Education Etc and it's not
that we want them to LEAP in with
Draconian punishments but I am concerned
that we need in some way to beef up what
we're doing where we have problem Street
Drinkers and um I would be interested in
Council keen's comments on how we might
do that in the next pspo the next
iteration of this where it links in with
antisocial Behavior thank
you okay councelor K thank you for your
question councelor Austin yes I agree
there are still problem areas very much
so and in actual fact coming into uh the
council buildings last night there was a
whole group outside I think it is a mult
faceted problem and it's worked on by
lots of agencies The Rise team forward
trust our own Community safety team so
it's ongoing with those efforts as well
as of course the police and I think it's
quite nice that we're combining the two
policies at the next thing and that this
pause you know the N9 Monon gives us
time to really look at where the problem
areas are and what actions we can take
to address them so I don't have any
immediate Med answers but I do think
this time will be a good time to reflect
on that and if anyone else has any
suggestions I'd be happy to discuss it
with them thank you thank
you thank you councilor Klean any other
comments from Members councelor Alburn
yeah thank you chair uh spookily enough
uh this morning I had uh lunchtime I was
having a meeting and uh Mr Gettys was
part of that and uh we we were meeting
with the uh town councils and Parish
council's um um
representatives and and this matter came
up especially came up in Ramsgate the
town clar of Ramsgate uh raised it
especially in Charlotte square and where
there are a number of people
congregating um police are aware of it
uh I have to say that reading um when
you read about the the in
uh item one the alcohol control in
public space it it gives you to believe
there in um section A that says to not
consume alcohol or anything the
authorized person originally believes to
be alcohol is sealed or unsealed vessels
that gives you the that gives you the
view that no alcohol can be drunk but
effectively the police can't will not
take action unless the the person
suffering from that alcohol is causing
uh disturbance causing offense to
anybody else within the area that
they're that they're drinking in so I
think once I fully support this I think
it's something we need to look at when
the joint uh pspo comes forward uh next
year um and and I think we need to do
that obviously in conjunction with the
police to find out exactly what they're
going to do um how they're actually
going to enforce this um and and and and
our other officers who will as part of
the community team will be um so I just
wanted to make that point CH thank you
thank you councilor Al and I mean it is
a it's something we're all aware of I
think and we we see around the district
particularly in the center of Ramsgate
and the center of Margate um so I'm sure
that we will want to consider how we can
make changes in the in the revised PSO
to improve the situation because
obviously um it's not just when it gets
out of hand it makes people feel
uncomfortable I think because they don't
know quite what's going on around them
and what to expect so it is something
that we need to address as a counseling
as far as we're able uh members uh any
further discussion okay is that agreed
agreed thank you um we move on to item
nine which is the purchase of five Homes
at Reading Street broadstairs for
affordable rent councelor
Whitehead thank you leader tonight
cabinet is being asked to agree to
firstly the purchase of five new
affordable homes using the additional
capital budget approved by council at
its meeting on the 12th of October 2023
and secondly the letting of these homes
in accordance with the council's
allocations policy at an affordable rent
as set out in the council's tency
strategy in July this year Council
approved an accelerated affordable
rented housing development program of at
least 400 new homes constructed or
acquired by
2027 as a potential addition to this
program officers have been contacted by
Milwood homes who are required to
deliver five new affordable homes as
part of their development at Reading
Street
broadstairs this requirement is set out
in the section 106 obligations for the
development they have been unable to
secure an affordable housing provider to
deliver these
homes as the homes have been designated
as affordable homes in the planning
consent and section 106 agreement they
have been designed specifically for that
purpose and accordingly are considered
appropriate for the HRA in line with the
needs of households on the council's
register or those living in temporary
accommodation ation there is a
significant level of Need for
one-bedroom homes as well as for larger
family
homes it is proposed that the new homes
are let in accordance with our adopted
allocations
policy the purchase of these homes is
part of our accelerated housing delivery
strategy ensuring that section 106 homes
are delivered and that the affordable
housing that we are entitled to as part
of developments comes to fruition and
does not disappear when this is the
housing that we need above else all El
as this is a revenue strategy it has
already been established that the HRA
will benefit from these Acquisitions a
year
13 the capital cost for these properties
is £800,000 with £50,000 provided for
Associated
costs this provides one one bed flat one
two bed flat and three three bed
houses very importantly this provides
social housing in an area of thanet that
is often inaccessible for renters
property and rental costs in broadstairs
are significant and acquiring genuinely
affordable housing within broadstairs is
often
challenging ensuring that all of our a
is accessible to Residents is incredibly
important and local individuals and
families should be able to remain where
their local connections
are Acquisitions such as this support
that
aim thank you to Mr jaon for her work
relating to this proposal and an ever
increasing property Market being able to
to deliver genuinely affordable
properties that would otherwise have
been lost is essential and being able to
deliver them in an area that is often
harder to access for those on Lower
incomes is incredibly
important I move the recommendation set
out in the report and I'm more than
happy to answer any questions thank
you uh thank you Council white have a
second Council
Kean um I just like to say um how
encouraging it is to see these further
proposals coming forward and although
it's a small number of properties in
this case um as you say it's in a it's
in an unusual area for us to be able to
um create new affordable homes so that's
particularly good news and I thank the
officers for their work in bringing
forward these proposals we look forward
to more of
them um anybody else got anything to say
no CC y i yeah just um uh Echo what uh
you've said leader and just highlight
under 2.5 the report um it's even more
optimistic saying that between year 13
and year 50 of this this will producing
cash flow surpluses to the council um so
this is a long-term project which is
have going to have long-term benefits to
uh to the council and our residents
thanks thank you members is that agreed
agreed thank you and we move on to item
10 which is the local Authority housing
fund round two which is councelor whad
again seconds out round
two thank you
leader this report recommends the
cabinet approves the use of £ 694,000 of
grant funding and £
7888 160 of HRA match funding from the
already approved HRA Capital program to
purchase five units for the LF round
two members will remember that this is a
grant that we have considered before in
the first trench we applied for and were
granted 1.19 million to provide homes
for those who arrived in the country via
the following approaches the Afghan
citizen resettlement scheme including
eligible British Nationals under this
scheme otherwise known as
acrs Afghan relocations and assistance
policy Arup the Ukraine family scheme
homes for Ukraine and the Ukraine
extension
scheme in March this year it was
announced that the local Authority
housing fund would be expanded by 250
million for a second round of
funding thanet has been identified as
eligible for Capital grant funding with
an indicative allocation of
$694,000 this is to purchase four homes
for the resettlement element and one
home for the temporary accommodation
element like lhf round one this is a
match funded Grant in order to use this
round it is necessary to match fund the
Acquisitions with
78880 of borrowing within the HRA
Capital program the properties have been
identified and must be purchased by the
31st of March
2024 for every housing acquisition we
complete business plan modeling the
modeling for this grant scheme shows
that the scheme generates a surplus from
year one due to the grant subsidy which
allows these homes to immediately
support further investment in the
affordable homes
program it is proposed that we set let
these homes at the genuinely affordable
rent in line with our approved tency
strategy discussions have taken place
place with a local developer currently
developing the Westwood cross site to
purchase 5times three bed
units these units will be an
off-the-shelf purchase with no
refurbishments or adaptations needed
they are nearing completion and will be
ready soon the developer has accepted a
provisional offer subject to approval of
1.4 million this amount is equivalent to
80% of market
value as with the previous tranch of
funding the time scales around this are
extraordinarily tight
in order to deliver the homes required
in the period given direct purchase is
the only realistic Way
Forward as members will know this aspect
of funding frustrates me hugely as it
limits our creativity in provision but
the net result Remains the Same namely
that we can support those who need our
support at an incredibly difficult time
for the allotted time that they are
allowed to remain by central government
and not only grow our general portfolio
but also support the growth of our
housing
overall these homes are significant not
just in what they can achieve in
supporting those who have experienced
war and displacement but also in what
they can do to support other vulnerable
residents due to the scale of this Grant
and its provision of 46% of the overall
cost the rental of these properties
produces a surplus from year one as
demonstrated by the provided
graph this is especially significant as
part of our strategy as it provides a
revenue stream to not only offset
borrowing to produce the 400 plus proper
properties we are producing for General
usage but also to support further
housing acquisition and
production it is exceedingly rare that
both moral and financial benefits align
this is one of those rare
cases life often calls on us to do the
right thing for others this moral
imperative runs through every decision
that we make as a council and is
especially pertinent here but to be able
to provide for even more residents
specifically through fulfilling our
moral duty is a circumstance that rarely
appears in local government but this
strategy allows it a huge thank you to
Miss Jackson for all her work on this I
move the recommendation set out in the
report and I welcome any questions thank
you thank you Council whad we have a
second councelor Yates and speaking
under 20.1 councelor
pford thank you leader uh just like a
little bit of clar sorry clarification
not just about um
round two but round one as well um but
that's what's what's before us today um
in the event of one of our um Afghan or
Ukrainian families terminating
tendency within three
years would it then be offered to
another
family and would that be for another
possible 3 years or would the on
termination of tendency would that then
go back to our housing
list
so thank you uh thank you for the
question so in relation to both rounds
of funding which I think is what you're
asking
for the grant conditions as far as I'm
aware require us to use it for as long
as we have need within those particular
populations so if for instance we did
not have any families that would qualify
for support under these
programs then that property could then
be used within General usage the three
years relates to the amount of time that
central government has allotted to those
individuals in terms of being able to
stay here um I think in the case of war
and
displacement it's a very difficult thing
to do to put a time limit on it and I'm
confused that that has happened happed
but unless central government guidance
changes on how people how long people
are allowed to stay that's why that
3year limit is there so it won't be a
perpetually extended three-year limit
which I think is what you were wondering
about it relates specifically to the
amount of time granted under these
schemes so can I just come back yep what
I mean is if it went then went to a
second family would it then be another 3
years and possibly another 3 years after
that no because it's
within these schemes are related to a
particular block of time linked to
particular conflicts so central
government has given three years isn't
the individual it's no no okay thank you
thank you thank you very much um I'm
happy to pass back to
Mr
thank
you thank you for that members any other
comments is that
agreed thank you we move on to item 11
which is the adoption of the broadstairs
and St peters's neighborhood plan review
which is
me under the localism ACT 2011
neighborhood plans can be prepared by
local communities and the led by town or
Parish councils or neighborhood Forum in
areas which do not have a town or Parish
Council ific Council adopts a
neighborhood plan it would have the same
significance as other development plan
documents for example the local plan for
the district B tears on some Pie's Town
Council has reviewed its neighborhood
plan the neighborhood plan review has
been examined by an independent examiner
and progressed to referendum as agreed
by cabinet on the 10th of August the
referendum took place on the 26th of
October and the result was that
2,268 people voted for the neighborhood
plan and 279 voted against it as more
than half of those who voted voted in
favor of the neighborhood plan the plan
now comes into Force as part of the
development plan and the council must
formally make meaning adopt the plan
within 8 weeks of the date of the
referendum this review of the
neighborhood plan supersedes the brw
stair and C Peters neighborhood plan
adopted in
2021 I therefore proposed
recommendations as set out in the report
that is that cabinet recommends to a
meeting the full Council that thanet
District Council makes the broadstairs
and S Peters neighborhood plan review is
there a second up councilor Kane second
members any
discussion no okay is that agreed thank
you and we move on to item
12 which is the adoption of the
Berington neighborhood
plan burington Parish Council has
prepared a neighborhood plan the
neighborhood plan has been examined by
an independent examiner and progressed a
referendum as agreed by cabinet on the
10th of August the referendum took place
on the 26th of October the result was
that 2 84 people voted for the
neighborhood plan and 174 voted against
it as more than half of those who voted
voted in favor of the neighborhood plan
the plan now comes into Force as part of
the development plan and the council
must formally make meaning adopt the
plan within 8 weeks of the date of the
referendum I therefore propose the
recommendations as set out in the report
that is that cabinet recommends to a
meeting of the full Council that thanck
District Council makes the burington
neighborhood plan is there a second
councelor Alban councelor Pew speaking
number
20.1 thank you uh chair I I just wanted
to I suppose add to this that I really
welcome this coming to Cabinet I think
it's been a incredibly long process much
delayed admittedly not by anything that
uh this Council has done but by delays
with the independent examiner um and I
think it's encouraging that we finally
got to this because it's uh been long
supported uh locally in burington and
and again the process has been very long
um the only question I would have and
and I I I don't
expect um I understand that it's
probably a hard thing for us to solve
but particularly when there are
instances like this maybe potentially in
the future where an independent examiner
is delayed um in in looking into an neor
plan I mean the delay with this was
considerable and I know that when we
were in administration we were trying to
resolve it with officers and it then
spilled over uh into into this labor
Administration as well so I appreciate
it's hard but I'm just trying to
understand if it does happen again
if there is anything that we can
particularly do to try and uh not
necessarily Force hands but get it
progressing again because of course it
creates a real level of uncertainty for
residents and there's only so many times
you can explain that actually it's not
out of our hands and we can't really do
anything about
it I think whenever I've discussed it
with officers the feeling has been that
that the particular circumstances were
unusual um I I've not been close enough
to it obviously because a lot of it went
on under the previous Administration to
know quite what what went on but I know
that you obviously had concerns about it
when you were running the council um and
um you know we wanted to get it complete
as well um so I'm glad we've got it to
this stage I don't I don't know there's
anything that the officers can offer by
way of comments on it they're not
looking very
enthusiastic Mr bar yeah I mean it was
quite a difficult situation I can't
really discuss the the personal
circumstances of the person involved
obviously
um but we did have a number of
conversations uh he actually attended a
session with burington Parish Council to
ex to try to explain some of the
background um and in the end we did
write to the examiner to say that you
know we had serious concerns about the
delay uh and the draft report arrived
soon after as the leaders already said
it was somewhat unusual situation we
found ourselves in it's not happened on
previous um neighborhood plans we did
have something similar on the on the
local plan examination where one of the
uh inspectors fell ill and there was a
delay of about 3 months so it you know
it can happen um but I don't think we
could have done much more than we did
but uh yes equally glad that we got to
the stage we are
at okay thank you for that I think that
there were a number of other delays to
the local plan process rather than
inconveniences with the
inspector no
okay uh members any comment on the
merchant and neighborhood plan well um
thankfully we've we've more or less
reached the end of the process it's
still got to go to council and no doubt
we'll be doing that in December uh is
that agreed members agreed thank you um
and that concludes tonight's meeting so
thank you members and officers for your
attendance
just put your r